a villain every good story
needs a villain you honestly think
that you're the hero in all of this well
of course i
am who else could i possibly be
[Music]
now as much fun as that intro was not
every story actually
needs a villain but there's a reason the
vast majority of them
have them there are a few better ways to
create and escalate drama than to embody
opposition to the hero
as a person but villains come in all
kinds of flavors maniacs masterminds
personal nemesis
and it feels like it's increasingly
popular to try and bring
some shades of gray to your villain so
things aren't quite so black and white
it's generally perceived as being a bit
more real
more mature since in real life it's
pretty rare that a true
clear-cut villain is going to turn up
and make our moral choices simple by
their existence
except that i've noticed that the
supposedly
layered villains still have a tendency
to do something that makes it absolutely
clear that they are
definitely the bad guys that the
audience won't question them being
stopped with violence
so uh i'm gonna be talking about a very
specific stripe
a villain being used in a fairly
specific way because
even your flat out wants to cover the
world in
darkness villain can be humanized by how
they interact with others and
finding out about their history things
like that no what i want to talk about
is villains who have
moral complexity at the start
and often times even for the bulk of the
story but who then
lose it maybe the cause they're fighting
for is one
the audiences might sympathize with
maybe the amount of harm or damage
they're causing doesn't
warrant clear violent intervention but
then
something happens or more likely the
villain in question
does something that undermines
contradicts or otherwise
removes the complexity from the
situation
what i'm not talking about is something
like
thanos where okay there is a point to be
made about overpopulation but we can all
agree that anybody whose solution
is to kill half the living things of the
universe definitely needs to be stopped
and thanos has already come to that
conclusion before the audience even
meets him for the first time a better
example from a more recent
marvel property would be falcon and the
winter soldier
there are a few characters in that show
who could be considered antagonistic but
functionally the primary villains for
the show are the group the flag smashers
and in particular their leader
carly now the flag smashers are fighting
for the people who are being
forgotten cast aside or disregarded as
the world tries to
get back to normal after the blip when
the previously dusted populists all
returned
because those in charge are ignoring all
the problems that previously existed
with that old normal and they're going
to end up rolling back progress in
numerous areas
do we really need to bother with a vote
it's a pretty understandable cause
and i go into this in my full review but
the story
still needs these to be our bad guys or
actually
it would be more accurate to say the
story needs sam and bucky to
definitely be the good guys and if these
are the people they're fighting
then there needs to be a clear right and
wrong
moral divide because otherwise people
might start wondering if our heroes are
actually helping
or not and to that end carly blows up a
building with people inside
it kind of comes out of nowhere it's a
surprise even to the people fighting for
her cause with her
but it marks carly out as someone
willing to kill innocent people
worst case scenario would kill the
hostages
and clearly our heroes are now right
to stop her now that's the example that
kind of got my wheels
spinning on all of this but there's
plenty of others out there
another prime example is bane
as depicted in the dark knight rises
this version of bane comes into gotham
and targets
the nolan verse equivalent of wall
street it sets about
tearing apart the lies that have been
used to force
tighter laws in the time since the
previous film now at the start
bane has a nice moral ambiguity and
ended up being more topical than was
even originally intended
as the film shoot was wrapping up the
occupy wall street protest movement
started
attempting to highlight the increasing
wealth gap between the top 1 percent
and the rest of the united states but
bain is also vicious and violent right
from the opening so there's an
interesting and complex villain here
or rather there would be if one he
wasn't also threatening to blow up the
entire city with a bomb
because a bad guy
and two he didn't turn out to be the
pawn of someone out for personal revenge
and
all of the eat the rich posturing was
just a front the entire time and never
the core philosophy
of either bane or italia al ghul
spoilers i guess
don't holler at me about that the
movie's almost a decade old and the
twist is
stupid anyways this could have been a
deep morally complex movie especially
since bruce wayne himself
is part of that top 1 there could be
some deep questions asked
of the story the hero and of the
audience
by making him examine at what cost is
his wealth
even come from in the first place but no
the guy with the dumb voice the big bomb
and he's lying about his motives so it's
totally justified for batman to punch
him in the
head oh speaking of batman there's the
ongoing depiction of poison ivy
this villainous has long had an
environmental angle to her activities
targeting polluters and the like but her
comfort with deadly tactics and her
willingness to align herself with
less ambiguously evil people from time
to time kept her on the side of villain
for a while anyways in the last decade
or two
the character has been gradually
shifting into the realm of anti-hero
or reformed villain and i suspect at
least part of that has to do with the
realization that
the only bad thing about her was her
tactics but her concerns about the
environment were actually pretty
warranted and having the most prominent
environmental activist character in the
dc universe be a
villain might not be the best look but
getting back to marvel
magneto is also an interesting case
introduced as a flat out villain but
given shades over time
in most depictions the dividing line is
where his desire to fight for the rights
of oppressed mutants of the world
crosses over into proper villainy by
having him believe that mutants are
actually superior to humans
and should rule over them this has been
handled in various ways by
various authors but let's take the first
x-men phone from 2000 as a test case
here magneto's plan is to actually force
genetic mutation in a group of world
leaders
turning them into mutants and making it
impossible for them to clamp down on
mutant kind
if only out of self-interest it's an
interesting plan
and as presented one without much of a
true body count either
so what the movie does to make sure that
the audience still knows magneto has to
be stopped
is they have the artificial mutation be
ultimately fatal and to have magneto
move ahead with his plans
even after he gets informed of this fact
you're so full of [ __ ] if you were
really so righteous
it'll be you in that thing think about
how much more complex the climax would
have felt if his machine
actually worked as intended if a ton of
people weren't going to die
but instead become mutants would you
still have cheered the x-men
to stop him of course by the second film
they just flat out have him trying to
kill every single human being on the
planet so we don't
even really need to worry about thinking
in those kinds of terms from there on
out now i i hear some of you out there
shouting what about killmonger so yes
let's talk about eric from black panther
he is an interesting case and i would
argue the strongest case for being able
to validate a cause
while condemning the person fighting for
it because falcon and the winter soldier
did try for this and kinda pulled it off
sam took up carly's cause by the end of
her mission and so
her goals were validated but the show
still forced things with that
building explosion and it was a really
clunky narrative contrivance
eric's a bit different what's
interesting here is
we know his methods well before we
actually know his cause
and by introducing his escalating
violence first
and his desire to use wakanda's
resources to fight for oppressed blacks
everywhere
second it's not undercutting the value
of the cause we're gonna send vibranium
weapons out to our war dogs
they'll arm oppressed people all over
the world so they can finally rise up
and kill those in power because doing it
the other way around
has audiences doubting the value of the
mission by the end because they would
have been asking
is that what it takes to fight for this
but by bringing in the goal
later it gives us context to the actions
we've already been seeing
and then we see t'challa our hero
actually engage and grapple with the
questions that are
begged by the presence of somebody like
eric
but eric was also never really a
stand-in for that
cause the way carly and the flag
smashers were he was a nasty piece of
work
first and foremost which allows for
questions about his purpose to be
tackled almost
separately from any question about
whether or not he should be stopped
the tactics and the mission weren't so
intermingled that it became
weird that t'challa ultimately did a
less violent version of what eric wanted
by the end
it made perfect sense and that's pretty
impressive
oh by the way don't think that these
sorts of things are limited to comic
books and superheroes in fact
it's not even a new issue going back to
the 1990s
there's the michael bay classic
the rock i'm sure some are going wait
there was a moral complexity in a
michael bay movie and
yeah actually there was well for a
little bit anyway
so you see the main villain in this film
is general hummel played by ed harris he
steals a bunch of
frankly gruesome chemical weapons and
threatens to fire them at san francisco
if he doesn't get 100 million dollars
yeah it seems pretty clear-cut bad guy
but here's the thing
he's demanding it from a military slush
fund that uh that's a pile of cash the
military has that isn't really accounted
for
on the books and the reason he wants it
is because over the years he's lost
numerous men in clandestine and black
ops missions and because of the
secretive nature of
that work the families of those men were
never compensated their actions were
never acknowledged
and on top of that we found out later
he's bluffing
this mission was based on the threat of
force
i'm not about to kill 80 000 innocent
people do you think i'm out of my
mind he did really steal the chemical
weapons but he
never intended to fire them if push came
to shove
so how the heck do you ensure that the
audience
isn't on this guy's side for the climax
oh easy you have the men underneath him
mutiny and kill hummel once they realize
that they won't be getting paid
and have them then fire the weapons
anyways it
makes no real sense because firing the
rockets won't
change the fact that they aren't getting
paid but who cares
now we can kill the remaining baddies
without an ounce of doubt that they
deserve it
close call sometimes films are even
trying to be morally ambiguous and still
end up copping out on it by the end one
of the first times i personally noticed
this whole removal of moral grayness
was in 2001 with the movie training day
now in this movie denzel washington
gives an oscar-winning performance as
alonso harris
a veteran narcotics detective taking
rookie officer jake hoyt played by ethan
hawk
out on the job to see if jake can hold
up on the streets that alonso has worked
for years the ethics of this movie are
deliciously gray
there is no question that alonso is not
a good person he has little use for the
rules i want
injustice is that not justice that's
street justice what's wrong with street
jobs oh i just let the animals wipe
themselves out god willing and the film
openly asked the question what if we
need somebody like this
to take on the worst elements to protect
the sheep you got to catch the wolf and
it takes a wolf to catch a wolf you
understand
yeah he's a bad guy but this is a bad
world and maybe it would be even worse
without him operating the way that he is
it's a question that jake himself
struggles with
right up until the point where we find
out alonzo has arranged for jake to be
killed
and then later we see the neighborhood
turn on alonso so yeah no he was
definitely totally the bad guy and
jake's a hero for taking him down no
question
that infuriated
me even at the age of 19 because
it would have been so much more
interesting to see jake
make the choice to take down alonso but
not have it be made clear whether
that was ultimately going to help or
hurt this community
now i don't just want to say imagine if
the moral ambiguity wasn't lost and have
this all be thought exercises
let's take a look at my own personal
prime example of a film
that never copped out on a moral
ambiguity of its situation
right up until the end let's talk about
gone baby gone
a 2007 film starring casey affleck which
was the directorial debut of ben affleck
now
quick note both casey and ben have
misconduct allegations against them in
the last few years and while i'm not
going to be digging into that right now
i do want to at least acknowledge it
and i don't want anyone to take my
praising of the film as defense
of anybody's actions okay okay uh also
uh spoilers like for the end
so the film follows a private
investigator named patrick as he looks
into the disappearance of a
four-year-old daughter
of a single mother things go messy and
the young girl is believed drowned
by the end it's learned that she is in
fact alive and in the care of a police
captain and his wife
who staged the kidnapping to get the
girl away from her neglectful mother
this leaves patrick with one of two
choices
leave a young girl in the care of a
loving couple of means
and let her actual mother believe her to
be dead
or report the whole thing bring
kidnappers to justice
and return a four-year-old to a broken
home where she's barely cared for
when the lights go out and you ask
yourself is she better off here or
better off there
you know the answer what's never gonna
happen and what i'm not gonna do
is have to apologize to a grown woman
who comes to me and says i was kidnapped
when i was a little girl
and my aunt hired you to find me and you
did you found me with some strange
family
but you broke your promise and you left
me there patrick chooses the latter
in direct opposition of what his
girlfriend thinks he should do so he
loses that relationship
the captain is arrested and the girl is
returned to her mother
when i was watching this i kept waiting
for the situation to become less morally
messy i was expecting one of a few
things maybe it would turn out
the captain was actually a child
molester was planning to later traffic
the girl
or he never was gonna just raise her
safely
or maybe once uh we get her back
into the custody of her mother we get a
reassuring scene
of the mother being more attentive and
making it seem like nearly losing her
daughter and china she needs to do
better and the audience could at least
hope for improvement on the home front
neither of these things nor any kind of
equivalent
ends up happening the girl is returned
patrick goes to visit the mother who is
on her way out for a date even though no
babysitter has turned up yet
patrick offers to stay with the child
and we find out that the mother
still doesn't even know the name of her
kids favorite doll
the moral mess of kidnapping is wrong
but it would have been an improved life
is left exactly
as is there is no moment of moral
clarity where it becomes crystal clear
what the right choice was
not for the characters and not for the
audience and it has
stuck with me ever since and i'll be
blunt it's not pleasant
it's a haunting experience it's not
uplifting it's not triumphant and it
sure as hell isn't cathartic
which is of course why it happens so
rarely don't misunderstand me on this
there's nothing
wrong with rooting for definitely good
guys to beat up
definitely bad guys but i can't help but
get a bit antsy
when films and stories and shows
introduce
some degree of moral complexity but then
never properly grapple with it
aside from a general sense of lost
potential
there are other issues to consider as
well the entertainment we take in
affects us not in a clumsy one to one i
saw that in a movie so now i believe it
kind of way but
rather in a marinating in the culture
kind of way
and if nearly every time a villain has
more complex moral questions behind him
the film ultimately removes that
complexity by the end
then the films are telling audiences
things may seem complicated but don't
worry
it's actually quite simple you can trust
that the designated bad guys are
definitely bad
and if villains have motives that appear
to be applicable to real world causes
and by the end it's revealed that they
are definitely going too far
or that the cause is just a front for
something nefarious
it's telling the audience to question
what might appear to be
reasonable motives now i need to stress
uh this is almost never deliberate it's
a natural consequence of creators
wanting to have their story not be 100
black and white
but also not wanting to give up the
catharsis of the heroes beating villains
but the thing to remember is that when
we lack real life experience
we're gonna draw on the nearest
equivalent
the media we consume now admittedly
the news probably has a more direct
impact but i'd be a little out of my
depth trying to parse that
and even acknowledging that
entertainment
has an effect too if you've never known
someone who took up a cause like occupy
wall street then
in trying to wrap your head around it
you may end up mentally referring back
to that big guy with the bomb who talked
about helping the poor
but needed to be stopped by batman even
if only subconsciously
the stories we tell matter and the
recurring patterns and the stories we
tell the most
matter all the more thank you very much
for listening
if you want to support what i do i have
a patreon there are rewards for every
tier of support
everything from getting to see videos
early to your name in the credits
and all sorts of other things but even
if you're not able to do that there are
youtube memberships and even
if you don't want to do that like share
subscribe they all help me out i hope
you'll leave something down in the
comments
and we'll talk about it but you don't
have to do any of it because
at the end of the day you're the council
i'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
bye